Ladies and Gentlemen,
please welcome John Anderson.
[inaudible]
well, Jordan and Dave, thank you
so much for giving us your time.
John anderson.net is basically
dedicated to something that is very,
very dear to me as someone who is very
worried about our country and where we're
going.
And it's that you cannot,
cannot get good public policy
without a good public debate.
And it's seems now we don't have
debates anymore. We just have abusive,
emotional mudslinging.
So that's the sort of
the background theme. Uh,
but then we come to this incredible
opportunity today to engage with these two
gentlemen.
And I wanted to get the ball rolling
by talking about a number of issues.
Firstly, personal responsibility.
Then I'd like to move on to freedom.
What is it?
Because it's not licensed.
It's not what so many people think it
is today. And how do we make it work?
I didn't want to talk about courage
because we're going to need a lot of it
going forward and you're
going to hear a lot.
I would see demonstrated some real courage
I think here and what we're going to
talk about and what you're going to hear,
what you're going to witness.
Then a bit about social media and how we
make it all work and then it's over to
you.
We live in an age when,
okay.
It seems that
there's a crisis of trust in our culture.
It seems that we are very uncertain of
our institutions and the people who make
them up and what their might be and
indeed the research backs that up.
The Australian National University has
been tracking Australia's confidence in
their politicians and the political
process now for many decades we are in
unchartered waters,
record numbers of Australians no
longer have confidence in the system,
record numbers of Australians now distrust
the political process and the players
in it.
Just more recently we've had the latest
of a series of royal commissions of
inquiry into various institutions.
This times banking and the financial
services and we learnt that we couldn't
trust bankers.
Now,
there are many trustworthy bankers in
case there are any here, but plainly,
people were deeply
concerned by what merged.
And you stop and think about this when
people are in relationships of trust,
harmony and progress can be
made when it breaks down.
How many and progress are impaired
and people flee for safety.
If you don't feel safe with someone else,
you'll look for the rule book and you'll
look for policing and you'll look for
protection. So that's a good thing. We've
had the royal commission of inquiry,
so we know what's been going on. It's
a good thing. We've got the rest,
78 recommendations, new laws everywhere,
new surveillance, new policing.
But it's a tragedy that it was necessary
in the first place that people have not
been doing what they've should
have been doing without coercion.
So now we've got a great big battle
as to how to resolve these things.
You say the law based approach,
but Jordan, you've said
something quite different.
Uh,
in the midst of all of us,
what you have said is that the
redemption of the world is not political.
It happens at the level of the individual.
That's not what we hear on the media
every night there's a new scandal.
It's we need more rules, we need more
policing, we need more surveillance,
we need a different party in power.
You're not saying that.
You're saying it comes back to the end.
The first question is do you want that?
Do you want a more a state
with more regulatory power?
Do you want a state with more
surveillance? I mean, first of all,
why would you think that that would
be trustworthy when all the evidence
suggests in the past that as the
state expands its surveillance power,
it actually becomes less trustworthy
rather than more. And why would you want,
you might think, well, I certainly
want someone looking into your affairs,
but I don't want anybody
looking into mine. Well,
good luck with that because you know,
to the degree that I have someone elect
someone to look into your affairs,
they're bloody well going to
be looking into mine as well.
And that just doesn't strike me as
a particularly positive development.
And practically because I
don't believe it'll work.
I don't think surveillance states
do make people more honest.
I think all the evidence is the opposite.
And then I would say from
the individual perspective,
it's like I believe that the,
the fundamental,
what we got fundamentally
right in the West,
because there was a number of things
we've got fundamentally right,
even though we don't like
to admit that anymore,
is that the ultimate moral responsibility
for the state relies on you.
It relies on your moral
integrity and you know you can,
it's not that hard to think that through.
It's like,
well first of all, you have the
right and the responsibility to vote.
And we can say, well, that's not
exactly given to you by the state. It's,
it's something that exists in some, in
some sense, outside and before the state.
It's part and parcel of
your intrinsic value. Okay.
So that's a decision that we've
made in the west, that each person,
regardless of their flaws,
is characterized by a value and intrinsic
value that's so deep and so profound
that the very,
a regulation of the state
itself rests on their shoulders.
And that's really something that's,
that's why you have the right to
vote and that's worth thinking about.
The first question is, well, do you
think that's a good idea or not?
I do believe that we are in
fact sovereign individuals.
And then while let's assume
that you believe that we are,
because the alternative is
some sort of autocracy, right?
It's some sort of tyranny. It's, it's the,
it's the parsing off of that sovereignty
to a bureaucracy or to some arbitrary
form of leadership and maybe you can
believe in that and you'd like a strong
leader and fine, but you want to think
that through because if, if it's not that,
then it's you.
Well then it's,
if it's you and you have to make sure that
the ship of state is sailing properly,
then the first thing you might want to
ask yourself is what makes you think
you're any more trustworthy
than the people that you're,
that you're despising or criticizing.
I mean if,
if you are well more power to you but it
isn't self evident that you are and my
suspicions are that it's not even self
evident to you that you are because it's
a very rare person that you come across.
If you talk to them with any
degree of seriousness, you know,
they're able to lay out a whole litany of,
of ways they fall short of their
own values, their own values,
not values that other people are
putting on them. Certainly that as well.
And they can name innumerable ways that
not only are they not doing what they
shouldn't be doing, so they're
falling short of the mark in that way,
but they're doing all sorts of things but
they definitely shouldn't be doing and
they know it. It's like, well,
we're going to put that right or not.
And my sense is,
you know,
I wrote a rule in my,
put your house in perfect order before
you complain about the world before you
criticize the world. What's
the idea? It's like, well,
you're the sovereign man.
If the states,
if the ship of state is listing
and sinking, that's you.
That's your problem. It's your
fault. You're not doing it right.
You're not educated enough, you're not
awake enough. You're not articulated in,
I tried to articulate it enough.
You don't know enough about history.
You're not taking on
enough responsibility.
You're looking for other people to
blame because it's convenient and, and,
and that's kind of understandable because
it's the dispersal of responsibility.
Who wants all that responsibility, but
there's a huge price to be paid for it.
The the first price that
you pay for it is, well,
there goes the adventure of your life.
It's like you could get yourself together
and be the bedrock of the state, right?
That'd be hard ad call on everything that
you have. That would be your adventure.
You're going to pass that off to someone
else and then then what do you do?
You've got nothing left in your life,
a triviality and you can't live.
I don't believe that people
can live ethically, trivially.
That's why I think the pursuit of the
idea that life is for happiness is wrong
because life is too difficult
for that to be the case.
Our lives are too profound
to characterized by
suffering and malevolence the
world is to characterized by trouble
at every level four happiness to be the
proper solution.
There is the solution is something like
a heavy burden of ethical responsibility
that kind that sets the state straight.
And then in that you find
the purpose of your life.
And so not only if you want the external
monitoring and the surveillance state,
not only do you sacrifice your privacy
and invite all that invasive intention
and lose your impulsive freedom,
you lose everything that's profound
about your life and someone takes it from
you, they take your destiny from
you and that's no way to live.
That's just,
that's the tyranny that we've struggled
against in the West successfully for,
I would say in one way or another for,
for for a number of thousands of years
and with a substantial amount of success
to draw, dive into this. We met
in la a couple of years ago.
I have a breakfast dive.
You're a great defender of culture to now.
When we met it was very interesting.
[inaudible] you set out the reasons, uh,
in a way for me to think he's
a card carrying progressive,
you know, you, you tell me where you
came from and what do you believe in,
what you didn't, and then you
said, uh, and I'm gay married man.
And then you went on to say,
and I thank God every day I live in
Christian America and I thought that's a
surprise turn in the,
and we had
a fantastic breakfast talking about it,
your defender of culture now all of our
cultural roots at a time when the West
seems to be its own worst enemy and
doesn't believe in its cultural roots.
Could you elaborate? Yeah, of
course. Well you know, first off,
as you guys I'm sure know Jordan and I
just left the Sydney Opera House a few
minutes ago and we've done about 120 some
odd shows where I've opened for Jordan
and it just struck me in the last two
minutes that having to follow you is much
less fun but having to go
before you, that's easy.
I'm usually just setting them up and
you're knocking it out of the park.
But okay, I'll try. Um,
well just quickly on,
on what Jordan said about the individual
because it links exactly to that.
You know, people ask me all the
time in the Q and A's and uh,
in our meet and greets what,
what is going on?
Why is it that people are following this,
a psychologist talking about
lobsters all over the country. And,
and actually that question is what I
believe is the answer there is there has
been a complete obliteration for young
people to understand what being an
individual it is,
what being a person that owns your own
mind that decides to get out there and
live the life they're supposed to live
that doesn't want to take from somebody
and give to somebody else
or just take for themselves.
And that has really been lost.
And what's been amazing to me is
we've done now 20 some odd countries.
Is that the same things that you guys are
thinking about in Sydney are the exact
same things that people are
thinking about in Toronto,
in Los Angeles and Stockholm.
And, and all over the country.
And that's absolutely fascinating.
So to your question,
because I am an individual,
that is what led me here,
that that's I think what led you to
want to have breakfast with me in Los
Angeles.
That the differences,
the immutable characteristics that we
either have in common or, or separate us,
whether it's sexuality or
gender or skin color, uh,
are completely irrelevant.
If we really want to be a
society that is truly free,
that truly respects each other, it
makes no difference. I mean, I do,
when I go to colleges,
I'll usually just single out
somebody in the crowd and it's like,
how sad would it be if I just
looked at you? And I was like, oh,
well you're a white guy. You look
like you're in your early twenties.
As if that would give me any inclination
that I would have any insight into what
you think or how you should think
actually is the better point because you
should think whatever you think and
hopefully be willing to have that exchange
of ideas.
Uh,
so I'm very appreciative that I live in
a Christian country because the simple
fact is, while the media
will imply that, you know,
every day there's another story on
how evil Christian White people are or
something like that.
And by the way,
I see that spreading all over the
world as well. I mean, there's a,
there's a weird thing going on with the
media where I thought it was really an
American, a crumbling of the media, but
now I see it all over the place. Um,
I live in the freest country in
the history of the world, period.
The United States in 2019 is the freest
place in the history of the world.
You, you know, with the,
with the most tiny exceptions
on speech around, you know,
yelling fire in a crowded theater
or a direct threat of violence,
you can say whatever you want.
And even being here in Australia where
you guys have it pretty good on speech,
I can tell people are jealous of,
of what America has.
And certainly when we were in,
in the UK where they have all sorts
of things where, you know, this,
this Youtube Creator Count [inaudible]
had his dog, uh, you know, do the,
do the Nazi salute and, and gotten
all sorts of trouble. I mean,
we won't have this forever. And
that, that's very clear to me.
And I would just add this,
that Douglas Murray,
who I'm sure you're familiar with in
the UK, um, he, he's also gay and I,
and he's a brilliant thinker and it,
I didn't even want to ask him
anything about that because it's,
it's completely irrelevant
in a certain way.
But the last question when I had
him on last time, I said to him,
do you think your sexuality
has a little something
okay
to do with your sensitivity about freedom?
Because you know,
it might be you first.
And he said that he thought his skin
was a little thinner because of that.
And so I do think that people that
are on the outside for whatever,
whatever that is,
it doesn't have to be sexuality.
It can be obviously a myriad
of different issues. Um,
I do think you become a little
more sensitive, sensitive to it.
And for that reason, I'm incredibly,
ah, I'll go a step further.
I am blessed that I live in the
United States of America and I can do,
I can live.
I'm a free man in the freest country ever.
And I'm very appreciative that
you can see why we get on I seriously.
Okay.
Can anyone push back against that?
And yet half the time when
you're listening to the,
the elites who have their hands
on the leavers of influence today,
you would think we lived in
cruel and depressive cultures.
Think of the four great revolutions,
the American war of independence,
and what came out of that.
Think of the French Revolution.
Think of the Russian revolution,
I think of a mass revolution,
which one that has produced a real
understanding of the individual
and secure their freedoms
in a greater way.
And we're in Australia of course,
are unbelievably blessed.
Do you use your word again because we've
inherited what's called a wash minster,
the best of the British house
of Congress. Uh, sorry, uh,
House of Representatives
based on the House of Commons.
Senators closely modeled on yours
and it works unbelievably well,
but you wouldn't think it listening
to the public commentary today.
Now let's come to freedom.
When you and I talked in Sydney
back just before Easter last year,
we had a great conversation then tomorrow,
enormous delight. I found that, uh,
we had a friend in common, Alexander
Salts or nights. There you go.
There's a fad or graph on him now.
It doesn't look very happy when
there's a good reason for that.
He would have been probably
busted up physically and,
and all sorts of other ways as well.
When that photograph was taken,
he was a hero in Russia
in the Second World War.
But after the war,
he dared to disagree with
the regime in Moscow,
which was an unbelievably evil regime.
And for the price,
uh, the, uh, the price
for disagreeing was it,
he ended up and the Gulag in a prison.
This is a remarkable book he
wrote about his experiences.
There were cetera. This was in the only
one I was smuggled out to the west.
There's no doubt that he's writing
shortens the life of that evil regime,
but the bit that stayed with me and which
you referred to and have many times,
you wrote a great essay on it over
Christmas. I recommend it to you.
It was published in the times and then
in the Australian or you can Google it.
Was it this black recorded that one
day was lying and he sell I'd imagine
freezing cold,
probably ill.
Incredibly.
I'm happy and he circumstances.
He hears the thumping of a guard down
the rows belting another prisoner up the
screams of the prisoner and
then he writes all of that.
It dawned on me as I listened to it,
that the dividing line between good and
evil actually doesn't lie between captor
and captive. Can you imagine a prisoner
in those circumstances are saying
the blog doing the beating is captive to,
he's not free.
Rather he said the dividing line between
good and evil lies somewhere across
every human heart.
It's not between man and woman to let the,
some of the people in today's movements,
it's not between Catholic
and Baptist or man and woman.
The dividing line between good and evil
lies somewhere across every human heart.
That was very profound
for me in public life.
And I was telling these friends on the
way out, uh, that, um, for example, well,
you know,
a point that came to me to be quite real,
I was a young federal
member of parliament.
I was in the outback town
of Walgett and I've very,
very angry young aboriginal
man came up to me.
He swore his head off at me
or you said you signed size,
you stole this from us, you
ruined this, you, you know,
an absolute litany of, of my crimes
and now you're going to pay us back.
And I remember thinking, stop, stop.
Remember that this guy has the stamp
of nobility on him too. It's just,
I can't see it at the moment.
Okay. You know, and I've
got no right to do him over.
He's like me, he's a mixture of good
and bad. But let's tease this out.
This incredible writer who eventually
was freed, found his way to America,
the Americans and the West
refuse to listen to his warnings.
He was there like a kind of prophet
saying, look out, you're
losing your freedoms.
Okay,
what did he mean? How do you find
freedom when it's not physical,
you can't move.
You're in fear of your life.
But in some other way he found freedom.
What's her name?
Can we unpack that because
I think it's important.
Well,
one of the things that soldier knits
and did, and this is something I think
we're thinking about,
I mean I thought about it for decades
because it's such a remarkable story.
I think he tells it in the second volume
of the Gulag archipelago cause it's a
three volume book, the f the full
book. Um, and it's all worth reading,
especially the second volume
and especially the second half.
And in that he details his transformation.
I would say his psychological or
spiritual transformation. Now,
um,
he was on the Russian front,
which was not a pleasant place to be
because Stalin had signed a pact with
Hitler and Hitler broke at and the
Russians were completely unprepared.
And so to be on the Russian front at
the beginning of World War II was a very
bad place to be.
And he wrote letters to a compatriot
who is complaining about the lack of
preparation. And that's what
got him thrown in the camps.
Now it's interesting to note that Stalin
through all of the Soviet prisoners of
war into camps,
so if you were a Soviet soldier and you
had gone to the west and fought and you
were captured and put in a,
say a German prisoner of war camp and
treated terribly because Stalin didn't
sign the agreement,
it was from Switzerland,
Geneva, Geneva accords on the
treatment of prisoners of war.
And the Russians were treated so badly
that the allies used to feed them,
you know,
and it's not like they were not hungry.
And so you would end
up in a POW camp there.
And then when you were done with that,
when you went home to Russia
for your hero's welcome,
you were thrown into the Gulag because
Stalin believed that the mere fact that
you'd been exposed to the West
now made you a class enemy.
So that was the sort of place to Soviet
Union was now soldier need to spend a
lot of time in the gulag.
And he observed that there were
people there who he admired.
Now the camps were mostly
run by the prisoners.
So because most prisoners,
many prisoners became trustees and then
would move up the administrative ladder.
And that's pretty interesting
and it really dark way, right?
Because it's like a hell that's run by
the devils and they can escape at any
moment if they just realized that they
were the ones running it, but they didn't.
And so, um, and so that,
that made the situation even more brutal
than it might have been because he
noticed too that prisoners who became
guards were often more brutal than the
civilian guards maybe to justify to
themselves what they had done. Who knows?
Anyways,
Solzhenitsyn at one point,
notice that there were people in the
camps who's comportment he truly admired,
who seemed incorruptible,
who wouldn't deceive or lie
or take the easy way out,
regardless of what it was that
they were being threatened with.
And they wouldn't sign the confessions
that everybody had designed,
guilty or not guilty.
They refuse to play along.
And some of them certainly died for that,
but many people died in the gulags.
So that was hardly an anomaly.
But he said that many of them,
many of the people who ran the camps
were terrified by these people.
And that also that many of
them were religious believers,
which was quite interesting.
And so what he learned was that
even under terrible circumstances,
there were ways of being
more or less noble.
And I suppose it would be under terrible
circumstances where that sort of thing
would be put to the test.
And it really made him think about
his own rule in his own demise.
You know, like he had Hitler
to blame, right? Because, well,
there was the second world war and
he had stolen to blame. And I mean,
if you need people to
blame for your misery,
those are credible people to blame.
You know,
especially both of them at the same time.
And yet he started to consider,
you know,
what did I do in my own life that
increased the probability that I ended up
here. You know, as a citizen for example,
who was responsible for the way that
the country operated because you know,
like in East Germany,
one third of the people in East Germany
were informers and everybody in the
Soviet system lied about everything
to everyone all the time,
which is of course what you would do if
one in three people were informers cause
that would be like two
people in your family.
And so the whole system was set up
and maintain because everyone lie.
You think, well if I stopped
lying, I'm done for, it's
like, yeah, fair enough man.
But if you keep lying and so does everyone
else you're also done for and so is
everyone else. So that doesn't seem
to be much of an option and social.
And it's noted that there were people
even under these extreme circumstances
that would tell the truth.
And he decided that he would go over
his life with a fine tooth comb.
He had nothing but time to think about.
Every time he had acted in some manner
in his life that transgressed against his
own conscience, right? That where he
did something, he knew it'd be wrong,
and then to see if he could figure
out how to set it right then. Now,
obviously he couldn't necessarily
apologize to the people against too.
He had transgressed,
right?
Sometimes you have to pay for something
you did in a currency other than that
which you took.
And his determination was to chronicle
his experiences in his truthful a manner
as possible,
which was basically impossible.
It wasn't like he had
paper and Pencil and, and,
and time to write and privacy. Had his
notebooks ever been discovered? Well,
he would've been in serious trouble and
they would have been destroyed. In fact,
when he got out,
he had two copies of the full manuscript,
each out to a different typist.
Secretly the KGB got ahold of one,
destroyed it, and the type is
committed suicide, you know,
so he basically memorize the,
the book and it's 2,400 pages
long of eight point tight.
Like it's, it's, uh, it's
one remarkable, um, work.
It's one long scream of truthful outrage,
you know, and that came out of
his decision to set himself right.
And then it was,
as John said,
it was smuggled into the West
where it had a walloping impact.
It completely demolished
at least for a long while,
the moral credibility of
communism completely from,
from like 1972 on, if you knew about
the existence of the Gulag archipelago,
you didn't get to say
anything good about communism.
And that lasted for a long time and
even convinced French intellectuals that
there was something wrong with communism.
And there's no doubt that it was one of
the historical events that caused the
Soviet Union to collapse. And that
was a good thing. And you know,
when it collapsed relatively peacefully,
all things considered
no thermonuclear war.
Yugoslavia was no picnic and you know,
but for the demise of one of the
most evil empires that ever existed,
it was pretty damned smooth. And certainly
the world's been in way better shape,
especially Africa,
since the Soviet Union has disappeared
because the African economies are booming
like mad now.
And it's partly because they aren't doing
things that are insanely foolish under
the guide guidance of, you
know, call me in this direction.
And so Solzhenitsyn decided under these
conditions of absolute powerlessness,
privation,
right,
to put himself together and
to say what he had to say.
And that was enough to knock over.
The Soviet Union wasn't,
it wasn't all that knocked it over,
but it wasn't nothing.
It's sold 35 million copies.
You know,
it's arguably the most
influential nonfiction book
of the 20th century and it's
unbelievably powerful. You think, well,
what power do you have if you're
willing to tell the truth,
it's not easy to tell the
truth. It's, it's complicated.
You have to take yourself into
account right over the long run.
You have to take your family into account.
You have to take your society into
account. You have to think it through.
You have to think strategically,
and then you have to find your words.
And that's hard to find your words because
you tend to use other people's words
or India.
Logical words are words that mask or hide.
It's not easy to find your own words,
but if you find your own words
and there are truthful words,
there isn't anything that can stop them
and you think, well do you believe that?
Well, let's go back to the idea,
are you sovereign citizens or not?
Well, if you are, well, why is that on
this? Because you have a certain faculty,
a certain power. Well, what do you have?
You have the power of your convictions
and your truth and your ability to
communicate and that's what's supposed
to set the state straight. Okay,
so you have that.
It's like,
well then maybe it's truth that you're
pursuing and seeking if you have any
sense and what true.
Well,
truth is the best reflection
you can manage of reality.
Imperfect because you're imperfect, but
it's the best you've got. It's like what?
What's going to be better for you than
to have reality on your site and what's
going to stand in your way if you
have reality on your site live.
I don't think so.
That isn't how it works.
And I don't think anyone believes that
because the other thing I've noted and
discussed with people frequently is if
you have someone that you love, a child,
let's say, and you're trying to
raise a child in a decent manner,
you don't tell them, look kid,
this is how the world runs.
Everything is corrupt beyond belief,
including you and your parents and,
and society and nature for that matter.
It's just complete bloody hell everywhere.
And the only possible way that you can
make it through life effectively is to
learn to lie as brilliantly and uh,
undisguised humbly as possible.
No one does that.
Well, why not? If you believed in fall.
So if you believe that
that was the way forward,
then that would be the right
thing to teach. But you don't,
you teach your children to tell the truth,
even if it's painful.
And the reason for that is
that you actually believe
in the power of the truth.
No. Finish that with one thing. There's,
there's a very interesting scene in
revelations is a very strange document
appended to the end of the primary
book in the Western Canon, right?
And it's a hallucinogenic
nightmare revelation. And in it,
Christ comes back to earth and he's
not the merciful savior of the Gospels.
He's the judge. And there's a reason
for that, a psychological reason.
And the reason is,
is that if you have an ideal
and whatever Christ is,
metaphysically, you're
psychologically, he's an ideal.
If you have an ideal, an ideal is a
judge because the ideal judges you,
right? Okay, so he comes back as a judge.
He has a sword in his mouth and he
judges that saved and the, and the down.
And it's not pretty, but here's something
interesting. It's so fascinating.
He saves his worst contempt
and uses contemptuous language.
Says,
I will spit you out of my mouth.
It really means I will vomit you out of
my mouth. Not if you were a bad person,
no one. If you were a good person,
not if you were a bad person,
but if you sat on the bloody fence,
right? If you are neither warm nor cold,
you wanted to play it both ways.
Well all lie when it's in my favor and
we'll tell the truth when it's expedient
for me, it's like you're, you're
in the category of the dam.
And I think that's absolutely right,
cause that's real cowardice.
If you believed in false hood, it's
like good. Get on with it, man.
You can be a criminal and lay your
life out and see how that works.
And if you believe in truth,
well then perhaps you put yourself
on the line for the truth,
but you don't play the, the two sides
against the middle because there's,
there's nothing in that,
that isn't
self serving out the cost of your own
wellbeing and up the cost of everyone
else's.
So you have to think about,
you have to think about your
relationship with the truth. You know,
there isn't anything more important
than you can do than that.
And because you're, you're, um, you're,
I've seen people in major corporations
that were corrupt and failing,
spend three years doing
nothing but telling the truth
often at their own peril,
fix the companies.
And it's such a relief to the
people that they were talking to.
Cause they'd go talk to them and the
company is run by people who are not doing
what they should be doing and
they're questioning. It's like, okay,
well what's really going on here?
Well,
no one wants to talk
because they're afraid,
but the person who's doing the
questioning actually wants to know.
When people start opening up and he
gathers information, it's like, oh, I see.
Here's the real problems here. It's like
we've got all sorts of problems here.
This is why the company's in trouble,
but it's okay if we know the problems
well then we can fix them and we'll go
ahead and fix them and then the company
will work and everybody who's terrified
and won't say anything,
it isn't really working hard
anymore because there's so
dispirited and believing
that the projects are corrupt and that
the leadership isn't doing what it's
supposed to, they start having a
bit of hope. It's like, really?
You mean you're actually willing to
admit that that is the problem and you're
going to give me a problem that is a real
problem that I could actually work on
and actually solve and benefit from that.
And the whole company switches around and,
and that works.
It's not naive to believe that.
And I'll say one more thing about
trust that's very much worth knowing.
So this is what you learned.
If you're a clinician,
most people who trust our naive
and naive is not a virtue.
It's a fault.
It's partly a fault because if you're
naive and you run into someone who's
malevolent, including you, they
might do you in calculable damage.
So then you will never recover.
So that's not a good thing.
You don't want to be naive.
If you're not naive,
that means you've been burned
once or twice or three or
four times. And you know,
once you've been burned in that manner,
well then it's hard to
trust because you think,
well why would I trust
you or me for that matter,
knowing full well that I can be betrayed.
And so then you're cynical and you think
that's an improvement over being naive.
You know it's, you're more mature,
cynical than you are naive.
Even if it's premature and
it's often premature and
young people, it's like, okay,
so how do you get out of that conundrum?
While this is a crucial thing to know,
you trust people because
you're courageous.
That's why it's the same
reason that you're grateful.
It's a mark of courage.
It's a mark of commitment.
It's like you and I were going to make
an agreement and you're full of snakes
and so am I, and there's lots
of ways this can go sideways,
but we're going to put
together an agreement. We're
going to articulate it out.
We're going to try to find something
that is of mutual benefit to both of us.
We're going to put our hands out and
shake and we're going to try to stick to
that and we're going to risk trusting
each other, right? It's a risk.
And that's the risk of on which the state
is based. Really. Like I, I believe,
and I think the evidence for
this is very strong, by the way.
I don't think that there is any other
natural resource than trust and for trust.
You need courage,
not naivety.
And you go to overcome your cynicism so
that you trust and then you ask yourself
too, if you don't trust your
institutions, it's like,
Hey,
they're your institutions. Why don't
you go out and do something about them?
You think, well, I can't. It's
like that's not true. That is,
that is absolutely not true.
That there's,
there's nothing vaguely accurate
about that. In a society like this,
almost all of our democratic
institutions are crying out for people to
participate.
They can't find enough people to do it.
And if you participate and you and you
do it diligently and you have your say
and you're careful and trustworthy and
you and you and you and you and you speak
your mind, you can have way
more effect than you think.
So if you're a cynical
about the institutions,
it's like look in the mirror
because those institutions,
the corruption of those institutions is
a direct reflection of your inability to
get your act together.
And that's what it means to be a
sovereign part of the western community.
So it's not someone else.
So
this issue of trust. Now I would have
thought that after what he'd been through,
and you've outlined it.
Yup.
Not alone by any means,
but some of these people who have warned
us of the need to be responsible and
uh, he'd history salsa. Nixon is a
classic example. What has happened.
Do you made the point that for a very
long time we understood how dangerous that
sort of drift towards totalitarianism is.
It seems to washed out of the system
now it seems as though we don't teach
history,
we don't respect it.
We don't understand that it
can teach us valuable lessons.
And what worries me about
that is they all saying,
if you don't understand history,
you may very well repeat it.
Why do we walk away from
people we can trust warning
us of the consequences?
What if it was an interesting reason
for that that sort of brings this salt
units in story into 2019 which
is that he was truly oppressed.
This was a life of actual oppression
right now that we have people that are
walking around, everyone in this
room has this in their pocket.
And if you have this in your pocket,
I hope, yeah, hopefully it turned off.
But if you have this thing in your pocket
and you think you're oppressed, you're,
you're very confused.
We,
we live in a time with such absurd
freedoms in the west that are so,
uh,
beyond imagination of what people could
only dream of two generations ago,
even one generation ago. Especially
with this, that people now are,
have a perceived depression
instead of a real depression.
So one of the things that
I find when I go to a,
when I go to college campuses
is that these kids will
protest and they'll scream.
And that,
you know,
that everyone's all right and everyone's
a neo Nazi and the rest of this. And I,
I always find, all right, well how do you,
how do you break through to somebody
like that? How do you actually,
when they have, you know,
you've talked about this,
when they have that look in
their eye, truly a possessed
look and there, you know,
it's this, this postmodern monster
has become sort of a secular religion.
Uh, and I think that's also one of the
reasons why we're Jordan's doing is
resonating because they've,
they've removed religion from the equation
and now they have no meaning and they
put it all into this really
competing set of ideas. Uh,
we're what we call the,
the oppression Olympics where they're
constantly competing for oppression
because they believe that victimhood is
virtue in victim hood of course is not
virtual,
it's virtual is getting your life in
order and going out and doing something.
So I'm always looking for a little trick
to get through to these kids and it's
really hard because when they have that
sort of glossed over Zombie, look, it's,
it's tough.
And I found one trick that actually kind
of works if you can get it to them in,
in the most simple,
personal way.
And this particularly works in the
United States and I have no doubt that it
would work here in Australia as well.
I'll say to them, anyone in this room,
does anyone in this room have it
worse than their grandparents?
Now I've done this, I don't
know, a hundred times.
Probably nobody has ever
raised their hand. Nobody ever.
If you live in the United States,
you basically short on the,
I mean the only outsider case would be
if your grandparents were oil barons or
something like that, and then they
lost all the money, in which case,
in which case the leftist would actually
love that too because it would show
that,
well,
it would show that that accumulated
wealth doesn't stay beyond generations.
So they're all about that. Right. So,
but if you can do something like that,
I mean if you say,
I mean everyone in this room can do it.
Like can everyone picture
of their grandparents? Do
you have a better or worse?
I mean, does anyone in here have
it worse than their grandparents?
And that shows you that it's a perceived
depression, not a real oppression,
that, that the thing that they're
fighting this patriarchal,
postmodern capitalistic thing that they
are fighting and they can't define it.
So it's hard to define it for them,
uh,
that it actually has bent
toward justice always,
always. And one when you get what
you can plant that seed in them,
I think it's a little bit of something,
but it's very hard to
break them out of that.
But I think the key here is understanding
that it's a perceived depression.
If you live in a free
society in the West in 2019,
you're not oppressed. You, you may be,
you maybe don't have as
well as your neighbor does.
And maybe you came from more
and they came from less.
Or maybe you're sick and they're
not, or a series of other things. Um,
but you've got a chance and that's
all you're supposed to have in life.
And I think getting that through
to them as opposed to, oh,
the system is horrible and I have to
now destroy the system as if they could
magically reconstitute a system that
really would just be an effect throwing
away thousands of years of human
history that there are so wise there.
So why is it 24 years old? Is there
shouting down speakers that they could,
they could build up what nobody before
them could and that that's the danger
there.
So I think getting them to,
to think about their own
lives where they come from,
I think is a pretty effective way of,
of getting through to people.
Well, we can also say like, look,
there's a claim that the west
isn't oppressive patriarchy.
And so that's actually true.
The,
the problem with the claim is that it's
not just an oppressive patriarchy and
there's a big difference between
something being completely something and
something being partly something.
Because one of the things you might
point out is that you can look at human
history anywhere and what you see is
a complete bloody nightmare, right?
It's,
it's,
it's death and struggle and privation
and war and horror everywhere with some
progress,
you know,
some ability of us to pull
ourselves out of the mire,
you know,
and the West is the same is there's plenty
of catastrophe in our past and of all
sorts. And, and I think it's,
it's necessary to know that,
but then it's necessary to separate
the wheat from the chaff. You know,
one of the things I see
with readers who are, um,
unsophisticated and intellectually
arrogant is they'll read someone great.
Maybe they'll read niches for example,
and they'll find the odd thing that
needs just said that grates against their
current moral sensibilities.
Whether they do that in context or out,
and then they'll throw
away the whole book.
It's like you don't throw away
the whole book. It was nature.
You don't throw away the book.
He's like one in a billion.
You read it carefully and
you think, well, okay,
no to that.
But yes to this.
And you do the same thing with
Dostoyevsky and you do the same thing with
Tolstoy.
You do the same thing with the great
writers of the past that had been down to
us. You, you read intelligently, you
separate the wheat from the chaff, right?
And you gain wisdom that
way. Well, you do the same.
When you look at your own history,
it's like,
well of course it's a bloody nightmare.
What do you expect? It's like,
what's your point?
We're going to,
we're going to burn it down and then
we're going to have something better as a
consequence. Well, not so
easily, not so quickly.
Maybe we read our history
carefully and we think, okay,
well what did we get right? Well,
what did we get right? Well,
the sovereignty of the individual,
that's pretty good.
The fact that you have right to property,
You can argue about the limits on that,
but you know,
you don't want someone just taking
your purse. You know, it's, it's,
it's helpful that there are things
that you can earn and own, you know,
the dignity of the individual.
That's another one. Um,
the innocence before the law. God, that's,
that's a miracle that we
ever came up with that idea.
I can't believe that that idea exists
because in most cultures it's like what?
You might be guilty, okay, your
dad cause well that's easier.
You might be guilty, you know,
why go through all the trouble?
There's plenty of people
where you came from.
It's like the trouble of presuming
your innocence, it's even innocent.
It's even hard for you to do that for
yourself. And, and, and the idea that,
that each person has an intrinsic worth
regardless of their well externalities.
Let's say. That's another idea.
That's a complete miracle. It's like,
what were you going,
what are we going to do?
We're going to throw all that away
with the statement that we live in an
oppressive patriarchy and then we're
going to be left with nothing and, and,
and what, what good is that? Well,
how about we look at our history and we
take responsibility for it. We think,
okay, well here's some things that need to
be fixed. There's plenty of them, right?
There's plenty of them for each of
us to fix and we'll go fix them.
And maybe then we can atone for
the bloodiness of our history.
And for our so called unearned privilege,
you know,
some of which all of us have.
And that wouldn't be good.
That would be part of the adventure
of your life too. And that's,
that's a far more sensible and wise
approach to the diagnosis of what's wrong
with the West then?
Well,
it's an oppressive patriarchy and it
should be overthrown or whatever that,
you know, current, uh,
low resolution and resentful
in the ology happens to be.
And, and there's something to be
said for a bit of humility as well.
It's like really,
you really think that you're
capable of making large scale social
transformations and getting it right.
Do you,
you really think that you're 25, you're
30, you're 40, I don't care. You know,
what makes you think you're smart
enough to pull off something like that?
It's very, very difficult. Very, very,
very difficult to take a system that
works not too badly and to do anything to
it that doesn't make it worse,
much less to radically reconstitute it
and make it better. That's really hard.
So you know,
if you're upset about your culture,
well maybe you could think of some small
ways that are local that you could go
out and improve it.
I think you should start
with yourself is because Bob,
then you're only harming yourself and
you're not a bad person to practice on.
And then you could extend
that to your fat. Well,
at least you suffer for the consequences
of your own experiments that way rather
than having someone else do it.
And then maybe you can work on bringing
a little more harmony into your family
and maybe you can get a job and
see if you're any good at that.
And then if you manage those
three things halfways respectably,
well then you could dare to put a toe
hold out into the broader community and
think,
maybe I have an idea here that we could
tentatively attempt that might make some
small things slightly better that we
could measure carefully and assess.
And that would be your contribution.
And maybe you get real good at that,
you know? So by the time you're 50 or
60 and you have a solid life behind you,
you're actually capable of generating
large scale improvements carefully.
Um, you know, as you were saying
that, I was thinking, I mean,
this is exactly what Alexandria
ocozzio Cortez is. I mean,
this is a failed, this is a bartender
with a four 30 credit score,
which is pretty terrible. Uh, but you,
all she's ever done in her life has
been a bartender. Now that's fine.
I've been a bartender at times,
but the,
her only accomplishment is
becoming a congress woman with,
I think around 15,000 votes by saying
the exact thing that the god that the
media wants you to say all the time.
Right.
The idea that she could write this a
green new deal and that somehow she is the
one that can, now of course,
she didn't really write it.
You're, you know, we're not,
we don't know who really wrote it,
but the idea that she could present
this as if she has the ideas that could
rejigger the entire United States
economy and how we deal with energy and
transportation and everything,
and we're not going to have planes and
we're going to pay people unwilling to
work. Although then she deleted that part
and put that, you know, it's like, it's,
it's the lack of humility there.
That's actually staggering that she
thinks no one before her might've tried to
move some of these things on the
margins a little bit, but she,
but crazy or that moving things
on the margins isn't enough. Well,
they don't believe it's enough,
but the really crazy part
of this is that pretty much,
I think the five or six Democratic
candidates that we have now have all
basically signed on board this
thing, this thing, which is a,
I think you could probably argue
that it's unconstitutional on,
on the grounds of,
it's just taking more for the government,
but because everything we know from
history about how economics, yeah,
well she's admitted. You can't,
they know all of Israel. She says,
we'll tax the billionaires.
And then she also tells you,
tells you that the billionaires are the
blight on society. So it's like, well,
which one is it because you need the
billionaires to pay for it even though it
won't pay for it.
And if you don't want billionaires
when now we can't pay for it.
So what are we doing?
Gimme gimme one you're going to write
it is Australia's longest serving prime
minister is a man called Bob Menzies
and he was a man of incredibly powerful
intellect and very,
very deep learning. Uh,
and he wrote fascinating me
that democracy is not a machine.
It's a spirit in which the peculiar
Christian conception that no matter what
your station in life is,
each of us has a spark of the divine
and every soul is of equal value before
heaven.
Why do I mention that?
Partly because I think it's a
very relevant point personally,
but it's because in the mocking and the
ridiculing have that respect for our
faith out of the door. We've knocked
that one of the pillars of democracy,
we've knocked out the idea that whether
I agree with you or not, doesn't matter.
I have to respect you because
they're a higher authority,
places as much value on
you as he does on me.
Now it seems that the problem is that if,
okay,
you did disagree with me,
I don't have a reference frame for good
and bad anymore or for respecting you,
therefore I have to insist on,
right,
so you're on God over my life and you
data challenge me because you want to be
got over yours. Well, that's a,
you're an evil person though.
You're a racist story
or something terrible.
We lack of framework for respecting one
another and it seems a massive problem
for us. It's the problem with
the collectivist viewpoint
because if,
if you're defining characteristic is
that you're a member of a collective,
then you live or die by the
propriety of the collective. The,
the antidote to that is that
strange metaphysical claim,
which is that well,
which is fundamentally that we each
have a spark of the divine in us.
And you think, well, it's
easy to be cynical about that,
but you shouldn't be because
you act like it's true.
And that's worth noticing.
It's like if you have friends or family
members and you don't treat them like
they have profound intrinsic value,
then they're not happy
with you. Right? You can't,
you can't have a loving
relationship without that.
You can't have a relationship
of reciprocity without that.
You can't have a relationship of
respect without that, none of it.
And they also want you to treat them like
they're in some sense masters of their
own destiny, which is
also interesting, right?
Because if you have a say a 21 year
old child and they're upset with you,
they say, well, I'm 21 years old, I'm,
I'm, I'm able to make my own decisions.
And you say,
and they want you to agree with that and
you want to agree with it because you
hope that there are ready
to make their own decisions.
And, and you, and you think,
well, maybe they have matured to that
point. So what are you saying? Well,
you're saying that they are gifted with
the ability to take the responsibility
to shape the reality around
them and they insist upon,
they insist upon you recognizing that in
them as a hallmark of respect and love.
And you know,
you might be irritated because they're
not acting responsibly enough to deserve
that, but it's still what you hope
for and want. And so like, well,
so what is it where the sovereign
cornerstone of the state, each of us,
what are we going to dispute that?
Well, we know the cost of that. Okay,
well do we have that spark of divinity?
Well, what do we struggle with day to day?
We struggle with the potential that's in
front of us and transforming that into
the reality that could be,
that's as close to a divine
faculty as anything I can think of.
It's completely mysterious that we can
wrestle with the the fabric of becoming
and turn it into the actuality of
being and that we seem to do that as a
consequence of our ethical choices.
Right? You make bad choices,
you think they're bad,
bad things happen,
right and you think
they're bad and so it's,
you took the potential that was there in
front of you and you made something bad
of it.
You can do that and you can also do
what's good and we know that of each other
and that's part of the reason that we're
granted let's say the right and the
responsibility of being the cornerstone
of the state and so that the idea that
there is that divinity in us, I think
that's associated with our consciousness,
whatever that is because
consciousness is a mystery.
It seems to give reality to being right.
What's being without consciousness,
there's no one there to perceive anything.
There's no one there to shape anything.
It's like, is there anything there? We'll,
our consciousness itself seems
to be what participates in,
in the reality of being an and the,
the transformation of potential into
into actuality for better or for worse.
So there's an ethical domain to it too.
It's like there's no reason for
us to be questioning these fun,
this fundamental assumption,
unless we think we have a better theory.
What is that? Well, it's your
race. It's your power structure.
It's like that's what you want.
You want to be judged on
by collective standards.
It doesn't matter what you did in, in
this forward, I wrote for the social,
and it's in book, you know the red, the
people who ran the magazine, red terror.
That's a hell of a magazine. Red
Terror. Because they said, well look,
if you're getting rid of the
bourgeoisie, you know, don't just be,
start stopping with the
people who own businesses.
You want to get rid of their children too
because they're infected with the same
damn evil spirit.
And just to be on the safe side.
How about you take out the grandchildren
to six year old, 10 year old,
doesn't matter. Everyone goes, you know,
and what happened in the Soviet Union,
everyone judged on their
collective identity, right?
That's how you're going to be judged.
I'll find something about your collective
identity that's not so positive, right?
Some manner in which regardless of how
pressed you are, you're also an oppressor.
You know, for you it might be your
mail will, that would do it. You know,
for you it might be that
you're middle class.
I can find some dimension of your multiple
collective identities on which you're
an oppressor and that's good enough to
do you in if you take the collectivists
route. The alternative to
that is no, no, no, no.
We have that spark of divinity.
It's associated with a deep,
deep responsibility and it's an the
ability that goes along with that and we
play that out all the time.
We play it out every time we play
fair games with one another, we have,
we have decent,
honest relationships with one another.
We have business arrangements that are
honest and work and we can cooperate for
long periods of time.
We take care of our children properly.
We take care of our old people properly.
It's all predicated on the same thing.
You have intrinsic value.
And even if you do something terrible,
let's say,
and I still have the,
the conviction that you have value,
then it's incumbent on me to say,
well,
you did something terrible,
but you aren't necessarily something
terrible and it might be possible for you
to shed that and to a tone and
to read, join. Those are good.
And that's something too,
and it's built deeply into our political
and economic injustice systems.
And it's, it's no time to be
abandoning this. You know,
especially when you look around the world,
you see as it's spreading and it's
spreading quite rapidly everywhere it's
spreading.
Things are getting way better.
So enough crisis of
confidence in the West.
Like we've got our house to put an order.
There's no doubt about that.
But I see no reason why we can't do
it unless we lose faith in ourselves.
And there's reason for that. Like life
is brutal. There's reason to lose faith,
but not in the final analysis.
It's, it's a mark of,
okay,
it's a mark of malevolence
and cowardice to lose faith.
The inherent problem with that though,
or just very briefly,
is that the people that are,
that are promoting these ideas,
they actually believe that the experiment
of freedom, which is all that it is,
they believe it is bad.
They believe that America is bad,
that the freedoms that
you've won here are bad.
And what's interesting is
I've seen such a massive look.
I was a lefty my entire life and yeah,
and I should be judged accordingly.
But I mean, look what I've seen,
what I see now is, look, I could sit up
here and give you my, my lefty credit,
right? So I'm gay, married,
I'm begrudgingly pro choice,
although I'm really struggling with that
one lately because the left has now,
especially in America, guns soap,
Anna's, uh, on the board issue,
it has gone completely crazy.
I mean,
they're literally quite literally talking
about post birth abortions. I mean,
it's, it's, it's really nuts. Um,
I'm, I'm against the death penalty.
I'm for reforming the prison systems
and for strong public education. I mean,
I give you a litany of lefty ideas,
right?
But I can't get invited anywhere by the
left or a democratic group or anywhere
by any of these people. But
you know, who invites me,
the Conservatives and I go up there and
I tell them all the reasons I disagree
with them. And the Libertarians,
I mean, I like the Libertarians,
they're mostly stone, but like, you know,
I'm also a pro pot. Um, but,
but why is it that almost
everyone right now,
I would say if you're a conservative,
if you're libertarian, if you're,
so if you're a classical liberal
or sort of a disaffected lefty,
if you're an independent and a
couple other things, if you're,
if you're any of those,
there's a great group of people right
now that are willing to agree to disagree
and get to exactly what your question was,
which is how do you sit down with
people without impugning them?
The only people we're talking about at
the moment that have any institutional
power, because you know, everyone, every
time you talk about this, someone says,
well, but there it's for white
nationalists here and that.
And it's like they have no power,
no one cares about them.
The media promotes them to make it seem
like they're massive and they're not no
one,
but even the right does a pretty decent
job of saying that these people are no
good. So all we're really
fighting is this hysteric what,
what was that study in the Atlantic
where it's only something like 8%. Yeah.
And the only 10% of them
think it's gone too far.
So something like 8% of the,
uh,
of people believe really in
this postmodern progressive
yup. View of the world.
And a lot of them are
shaky within that belief.
So it seems like a big monster because
the media is always pushing it on us
because they are allowed. But I, I'm,
I'm extremely enthused that we've got all
over the world and met good people who
were, who were, I think need to
be a little braver perhaps, but,
but are here and are willing to,
I want to call that bravery
and amendment. I bet that, um,
what you've just said reminds me
of two remarkable men in history,
a GK Chesterton and George Bernard Shaw.
They disagreed on just about
everything you could think of,
but I loved each other's company.
Now isn't that incredible?
They couldn't wait to be together to have
another good argument and a good feed
together. That's what we need.
The genius of Western harmony,
surely as lion in our ability to respect
one another even over our deepest
differences. And one day, yeah,
Chesterton was huge. He was six
foot four and very, very heavy.
George Bernard Shaw was in great shape.
Like you'd take fellows and um,
and at GK test it and looked at George
Van Chore slimmers a Rake and he said,
bye g George,
you look as though they must be a famine
in England and George Freeman shore
shot back as quickly as you got to
imagine there's a great big dog,
Andy and Matt and you
look like you're the core.
But you just mentioned curry.
I want to get to some of the terrific
questions and people who've put up before
I do
curry.
Just something you've both displayed
in spite falls and it's incredibly
important.
We live in a culture now where
I think there's a lot of fear.
When I was last with you were at,
and there's
a thousand people in our auditorium,
a lot of them are young
men and I looked around,
I thought these are
terrific young Australians.
They pretty concerned about whether their
masculinity might be toxic and they're
pretty fearful about speaking out because
you know we had once upon a time we
used to burn people at the stake and
where and then we went for the guillotine.
Then we went for the hangman's noose.
Now we kill people in
social media and we do.
People get kneecapped every day and worse.
I think we owe you a great debt,
both of you actually, because you
dared to break the ceiling. And Dave,
you actually asked Jordan about this in
Norway. This is the beauty of modern.
Even. I caught up a bit, you know,
I heard your conversation. You said,
did you ask Jordan?
Did you expect when you started on this
journey to end up like this and you
asked him what it's like
to break through that,
how do you feel about it when
you're attacked and, and,
and you were very open
and very honest. Uh, and,
and you said that it's very tough
when a journalist does. You're over,
but you might like to repeat
that question to Jordan. Well,
quickly on the bravery thing,
my partner hates when I say this,
but I don't consider myself brave. I am
doing what I think is right. That is it.
That really is it. I wake up every
morning and I feel that I have a,
I have something to do that's relevant
and important and being on this tour with
Jordan has been life
altering and not only for,
I live for all the people that show there,
but I don't,
I don't view it as bravery.
I couldn't not do it,
I guess is the best way to say it. I got
her. I just got to make the point there.
I think you're probably
being very tough on yourself.
I think the reality is that courage
is not so much not knowing fear.
It's overcoming it,
isn't it?
And there must've been times when
you've wanted to sort of say to you,
I don't want to be under this attack.
Well, I guess I saw it enough when I,
when I started waking up to some of what
was going on on the left and I had seen
the tactics over and over and
how they destroyed good people.
I suppose that as that went on and
as I woke up and got out of it,
I just became numb to that. And I just
wouldn't, I just wouldn't live like that,
I would think.
Um,
but the question that I
asked you in Norway in effect
was you didn't set out for
this when, when see 16
came around, you know,
you were doing all sorts of other things.
You got to practice,
you were teaching all of these other
things and you yet you've survived these,
well,
it's not even the attacks.
You've survived a road that
you didn't plan on being on.
And the bravery that you've shown along
the way is why people keep coming back.
They keep, they're rooting for
us more as, as you often say,
it's like these hit pieces come
out and then in a weird way,
and now I see it with me.
They've moved on from you by the way.
They're working on me now. But uh, yeah,
yeah, I'm happy. I'm happy to help.
But in a weird way,
it wasn't that you reveled in it,
but you made a point of saying, look,
every time they do it, I'm still here.
And I think I really took me awhile to
understand that because I always want,
you know, I wanted to defend my friends,
but I also wanted to defend myself.
And now it's like, all right,
keep coming. I'm still here.
We must be doing something right because
I don't spend all my day attacking
other people. I'll gladly attack ideas,
but I don't attack people. I mean,
I don't think we've done anything up here.
Where are we attack the singular
person. Right. And that's a,
that's a huge difference.
So the question really was you
inadvertently in a weird way,
I'm not a big fan of Cortez. Okay,
fine, fair enough. Uh, yeah, exactly.
So every now and again though,
but I think I talked about her ideas
and I've heard talk about that in the
public sphere. I talked about her and her
credit score, but you know, not her as a,
as a person,
but right.
And she is in the public sphere
and it's also impossible to,
to never talk about people.
So it's you keep,
you can't be that lofty all the time,
but you can try to be a little bit,
but that basically you inadvertently
ended up in this position where now by
virtue of showing bravery,
well you sold out the Sydney
Opera House in five minutes.
It's a matter. I think it's a matter
of being afraid of the right thing.
That's the issue.
It's like I decided a long time ago,
partly from reading soldier and it's,
and that I was going to try to be very
careful with my words and I was only
going to say things that I thought
well to begin with were lies.
Let's say I was going to try to
formulate my thoughts truthfully.
And the reason I decided that was
because I thought that the opposite was
hellishly dangerous.
And I really, I really,
I really believe that.
I truly believe that.
And so if I say things and I think
they're true and they get me in trouble,
then I think,
well that's not as much trouble as I
would have got into if I would have said
something that wasn't true. Like it might
be more trouble right now. Who knows?
Right. Because you and you don't know
how these things are going to turn out.
And I had this interview,
most of you know about it with Kathy
Newman from Channel Four. Right.
And that was a pretty strange experience.
Um,
so what you're saying is it
was a great interview. Yeah,
exactly. Exactly, exactly.
And you know, she was pretty
professional when we went to the studio.
Like someone like that is professional
kind of hard surface and glossy and, and,
and media presentable, you know,
the TV turns you into that.
And she was perfectly polite in a
professional way until the camera went on.
And then, you know, and then
she went after me and um,
and then the whole interview when,
when the way it went, and I thought, I,
I have like 20 interviews that day.
And,
and so I walked away from
that and I thought, Oh God,
they're going to take seven minutes of
that and you know, broadcast it and,
and make me look like a complete monster.
And that'll be the end of that.
And that is exactly what they did,
except they also posted the
entire thing on youtube,
not knowing at all that it was
a train wreck. He had no idea.
It wasn't like they thought,
oh, this is a train wreck.
We better put it on Youtube.
It wasn't that at all.
They thought it was a
perfectly fine interview.
So then it went on youtube and so,
well, so like my mood changed a lot.
It was first of all, well this interview
went catastrophic Lee. And then it was,
well they're only going to use seven
minutes of it. That's going to be a drag,
but I'll probably get over it.
And then they put it online and then
there was just an incredible reaction and
then five 10 newspapers came out to
play the victim card for poor Kathy,
which was now all of the
online trolls were after her.
And I thought that really,
really struck me.
I thought she's one of the
most powerful people in the UK,
you know, one of the thousand
most powerful, let's say,
or the 500 most powerful.
She's no bloody victim and
she's played paid plenty. Well,
for what she does,
Jordan, by the way, don't forget that that
night that this all happened, she was,
she did a video in her car reading
the troll, the comments by the trolls,
because at that moment she didn't realize
she should play the victim card yet
she was reveling in
it. Yeah. Right, right.
That's what it was
until she realized that,
yeah, yeah, yeah. And so then
her, her employees said, well,
we had to call in the police to
investigate. What does that have to run?
Unbelievably crooked thing to say.
It's like anybody can call in the damn
police to investigate anything. It's like,
well, what constitutes a
credible threat? Well, there,
there are ways of assessing
credible threats. You know,
they have to be direct and
detailed. That's, that's how
you assessed suicidality.
For example,
if you tell me that you have a plan,
you know when you're going to do it,
you know where you have a gun,
you've thought it through, it's
like that's a credible threat. Um,
sometimes I wish I wasn't here.
That's not a credible threat.
And you'll see the same
sort of thing online.
Well then 10 newspapers
played the victim card.
That poor Kathy was being trolled by Bob
at that point by like a million trolls.
Who knew there were that many trolls.
But apparently they were.
And then I thought,
well God,
the whole thing is going to go sideways
again because I'm going to come out of
this as the villain who called forth,
you know,
the alright armada to take down.
Poor,
innocent Kathy Newman.
And so it looked like it was going to
shift that way for about four days.
And then, well, that didn't work.
There was a couple of other interviews
that started to push back that narrative
and, and then it switched
back to my side. But look,
I'm making a point with this is when
I do an interview like this interview,
um,
I don't,
I follow this rule in my book rule,
which is it,
let's see. I think it's eight.
We've been doing this for awhile.
It's seven. Oh, do what is meaningful,
not what is expedient. Okay.
So I come to an event like this and I
have an opportunity to say things and I
don't come in here and think,
okay,
here's a bunch of things I want to
convince you up. You know, it's, I,
I don't care if you're convinced.
It's not like I don't care
about you and you know, in,
in the sense that you care for
people and hope the best for them.
But I don't care if you're convinced I,
that's not what I'm here for.
What I'm here for is to hear the questions
and try to figure out what I think
about them. And then to say that
and then to see what happens.
Like who, who the hell knows what's going
to happen? But there's, here's the if, if,
if, if the world is properly
constituted through truth,
then faith is the willingness
to have faith in truth.
And so then you say what you believe to
be true and then some things happen and
sometimes they're not so good, which
is why people often lie. You know,
you tell the truth, you get in trouble
for it. Every kid knows that. It's like,
well, why'd you lie? Because I
thought I'd get in trouble. Well,
obviously it's like, well, that's
not a good longterm strategy.
It's like so you say what you believe
to be the truth and then you have the
faith that no matter what happens,
if you've said what you
believe to be truth,
whatever happens is the best thing that
could've happened and I believe that.
I think that's how the
world is constituted and so
it's not bravery. Exactly.
I would say it's more like faith.
It's like I'm going to say what I think.
I'm going to try to do that as carefully
as I possibly can and I'm going to
detach myself from the outcome because
sometimes they'll comes terrible.
I met McMaster university or Queens and
there's like a bloody mob of zombies
pounding on the window. You know,
it's a little slice of hell.
You think there's doesn't
seem to be a very good idea,
but you know the tide turns two or
three times in the next three weeks and
something comes out of it. And so if
you're going to have faith and truth,
it can't just be, well, did I get
what I want in the next second?
That's not, that's not faith. It's
like, no, I'm going to, it's an,
this is the other thing too
that you got to understand,
I think is that without truth,
you don't have the adventure of your life.
You see,
because if you tell the truth,
that means you revealing your being.
That's what you're doing when you're
telling the truth and when you,
when you reveal your being,
then you're,
you're living in the world. You're
there, you're present, right? You're,
you're, you're, you're,
that's being there.
Let's say that's you, that's your
destiny, that's your journey,
that's your adventure. That's what's
going to justify your life, the adventure.
It's not going to be easy,
but my nephew hide from your truth.
Well then you hide from yourself
and then you're not even there.
And then who the hell are
you? What are you, the puppet,
you're the puppet of some coward.
You're the puppet of some dictator
or some second rate philosopher,
some idiotic idea or a bully
you were afraid of in grade six.
God only knows,
but it's not you living your life and
then you lose your life and you lose your
soul to soul. That's what
I'm afraid of. And so,
you know, journalists swell, they
tried to take me down. It's like, yeah,
well that's annoying. And it usually
takes me three days to recover,
but compared to not having my life and,
and, and, and not saying
what I have to say, that's,
that's nothing. It's nothing. It's,
it's minor inconvenience. And
then generally, if you can,
if you can just withstand it, you know,
two weeks you get mobbed. You guys are,
might only need to know this. You're
going to get mob on social media. Okay?
So what do you do?
Unless you did something wrong,
don't apologize.
That's the first thing.
Cause the no one can come to your defense.
So don't apologize.
Maybe you even doubled down carefully,
carefully,
not Vinge fully right carefully.
You say, no, that's what I meant.
And if you don't like it too bad and
you get more, then you apologize.
A different mob comes after you. That's
not helpful and no one can defend you.
If you can hold out for two weeks,
you'll win.
Now it's a pretty brutal two weeks.
Cause you know,
if you're a reasonable
person and a hundred angry
neighbors show up at your door
with pitchforks, you might
be thinking there's something
wrong with you. You know,
like you think that unless you're
a psychopathic and you think,
well maybe I made a mistake and it's
easy to waver and to and to back down.
And maybe you're also afraid,
but you know,
if you scoured your conscience and you're
careful and you said what you had to
say,
then leave it lie.
And if they'll throw the people who are
playing this game will throw everything
they can at you for two weeks
and if it doesn't stick,
you're done.
And then the next time they try it,
it doesn't work as well
as it did the first time.
And by the 50th time they try it.
Like as far as I can tell carefully,
the people who have enmity
for me are out of ammunition.
They're done. I read hit
pieces now and I think, oh,
you just copied the hip
piece from two months ago.
It's like I'm perfectly
habituated to that.
They're out of ammunition
and maybe you know,
like someone creative could still
come up with some more ammunition.
Maybe that'll happen at the Q and a,
but it's not bravery,
man. It's faith in the,
in the redeeming power of
truth and that's different.
That's incredibly
interesting and encouraging.
That's come through a couple of questions.
Yup.
I'll just preface them
by saying [inaudible]
we actually did a bit of research on this
and one of the things that people say
is they love hearing your stories and
I love hearing you being open and they
love it when you connect
personally with them.
And somebody wanted to connect with you
and Tammy Tammy's here with you on the,
I think very conscious of the
incredible timetable that your setting.
So is Allister there you wanted to
ask about how this works for you?
It's so great.
I the opportunity for both of you in
person in a moment of uncharacteristic
courage, uh, close to two
years ago I got married again.
A woman who on any objective measure
completely outranks me. Congratulations.
Thank you.
Now she is very high on assertiveness
and I'm very high in conscientiousness,
which you will fully
understand and so we can tend,
we contend a lot and it's good
and we're going somewhere good.
And I'm very proud for what it's worth.
Um,
I'm aware and I imagine what your life
is like and I'm talking to you Jordan,
but Dave,
I don't want to exclude you either.
And I imagine your life being
one of constant exhaustion,
exhilaration and probably a
fair bit of terror as well.
And the word contending is one that
you actually used a few days ago on a
different platform in a different city.
You're talking to young people and you
challenged them to marry him mate with
whom they would contend. And I think
of Tammy and I think of you and,
and we don't hear a great deal
of of Tammy, but you guys are,
I'm sure working really hard.
You're contending,
you're confronting all this stuff and
you're processing it and I'm sure your
marriage is strengthening.
I trust it is.
And I'd love some insight on that if you,
if you can speak to what you're learning
about marriage in this season of your
life.
Well the first thing we're doing is the,
Tammy is traveling with me,
so that's very helpful and she's
paying attention, you know,
so and we talk a lot about what is
going on but also a lot about our family
cause there's complicated
things going on in our family.
Like there are in most families and we
do our best to communicate, you know,
and she says what she thinks.
And I say what I think.
And we don't always think the same thing.
You don't,
but we do our best to listen.
We do our best to assume that just
because the other person has a different
opinion doesn't mean that they're wrong,
even though it would
be lovely if they were.
And then we try to come up with a
negotiated solution that's mutually
acceptable, you know, and,
and we discussed strategy as
well. I mean, for example,
when we started this tour, which was
more than a year ago, we thought,
you know, there's a lot of competing
things that you could think about a tour,
especially when we have no idea how
long it would be. Like, what was this?
Was this a vacation? We
were going to, you know,
spectacular cities all
over the world. Um, um,
was it time for us to spend together?
Like what was it, what were we doing?
And we spent two hours thinking,
it's like, no, this is work.
We have a remarkable
opportunity here. And, and,
and we're going to do the work. We're
going to hit as many cities as we can.
And so what does that mean?
It means we get the up in the morning,
we make sure we're packed,
our suitcases aren't too full,
we don't carry anything that
goes underneath the plane.
We make sure that I don't get hungry
because then I can't perform properly.
We make sure that I met the theater at
the right point in time and we make sure
that our eye is focused on the fact that
it's a great privilege and it's very
unlikely that we can do this. And so
we thought, okay, that's the deal.
And then we thought,
well,
and then we can take an hour or two
here and there if we're fortunate to see
some of the city and to take a break and
to do that when we count. And you know,
we've negotiated other details about
exactly how intense the scheduling was
going to be.
But it's a constant negotiation and
it is a contentious negotiation,
which is good because these
things are complicated, you know,
and to think something
complicated through,
you need a good argument on this side and
you need a good argument on this side.
And then you got to have add are and see
if you can come out with an even better
argument as a consequence.
And so that seemed to work.
Now there's other advantages. It
turns out the Tammy is very suited. I,
I'm sure I'm speaking from for her,
but she doesn't have a microphone actually
prefers to stay in the background to
some degree for various reasons.
Um,
she's very suited to a life like this.
She's quite stable emotionally,
so she, she doesn't suffer from a
lot of anxiety. She likes to travel.
Um,
she likes meeting New People,
she likes the adventure and
she's supporting what I'm doing.
And so that's working
and thank God for that.
And then she also keeps an eye on
what I'm doing and lets me know
when it's going well and when she thinks
it needs improvement and, and, and,
and she helps me figure
out where I'm going next.
Because for the last two years my schedule
has been so busy that I don't know
what I'm doing next, usually maybe
the next day. And so her job,
because we've also parceled out jobs,
is to make sure that I get wherever
I'm going next on time and ready.
And so far that's brought,
I would say in Calkin bull
benefits fundamentally. And,
and because we agreed on it,
we had our little constitution in place,
we were able to handle the stress because
I think we've been in a hundred and
it's damn near 150 cities in 350 days.
And so it's very heavy traveling schedule.
But Andy,
the other thing too is I trust her.
She tells me the truth.
It isn't necessarily what I want to hear.
Well you can tell that's the truth,
man.
That's what you don't
necessarily want to hear.
But so she's a very good counselor.
And that's turned out to be
exceptionally helpful. So,
yeah. And I'm like their
son who refuses to leave.
Yeah, I like it, Ma. Yeah. Really Nice.
That's all right.
I think we ought to give
Tammy a round of applause.
[inaudible]
Dave, I think one for you comes
from Monica Wilkie. Uh Oh.
It's about dealing with difference.
Thank you John. Uh, Dave, I wanted to ask,
is it possible to come to a resolution
with someone who has different values to
you? So for example, if I have
free speech is my highest value,
and I'm talking to someone who believes
that diversity and equality is a higher
value and therefore free speech should
be quelled in order to achieve this.
Is it possible to reconcile
these differences?
I think it is the best
example that I can give you a,
and I'm sure some of you have seen this,
I've had a couple interviews
and debates with Ben Shapiro.
Now Ben is an Orthodox Jew.
He does not believe that gay
people should be married. He, well,
he believes that being gay is a sin
is the loose word for it. Right.
Um, now Ben, my studio is in my home.
I live with my partner
and my home obviously. Uh,
Ben and I were friends to, uh, to a
certain point, you know what I mean?
Like you've got like your best friend in
life who knows you the way your husband
or wife or partner knows you.
And then,
and then you have sort of other
tiers of friends. Ben will never,
as long as we have this
disconnect, there's, you know,
last time I had them on when we
discussed this, he said that, you know,
it caught fire on the Internet. He said
he wouldn't bake me a gay wedding cake.
Right?
Or even come to an anniversary party
because it would be celebrating something
that he doesn't believe in. And I remember
when we were having the discussion,
I thought, all right, well here's
a really interesting moment.
I can now berate him and I can
demand that he acquiesce and,
and put aside whatever his beliefs are
so that he will believe what I want him
to believe, even if I think it
is the right thing. I mean, I,
I think I'm a good person. I'm doing
what I'm just doing my life as I see fit,
right? Ben Sees the world differently. Um,
so can we ever truly get through that?
I would say yes because what we agreed
to for what we were agreeing to disagree
on, what we agreed to agree on was that
it's not the role of the government to
decide who can get married.
Now he's less thrilled with that than
I am because I think that's a perfectly
fine position to take.
He, he, you know this,
you see this a lot with
conservatives now where they,
when you ask them about gay marriage,
they'll take the libertarian position.
They weren't taking it five years ago,
but they suddenly,
now that they realize it's the law of
the land in the United States and it's
just the easy way out.
It's like, well, you know,
I don't really care about gay marriage.
It's anyone can get into any, uh,
contract that they want to. It's
the easy way out. I don't, uh,
letting them slide on that
because we're equal. We're we,
we made it so it's okay now.
So I don't know that you can ever,
okay,
well let's put it this way.
I think there are issues that you will
have existential profound differences
with people that you will
not be able to get over.
But that doesn't mean you have
to cut them out of your life.
And as I said to Ben last time we talked
about this, I hope that, you know,
we'll remain friends to whatever
degree our friendship is for the next,
let's say 50 years. And I'm a little
older than him, but when I'm, you know,
92 and he's 37 or whatever
it is, or 37, sorry, what?
He's a 87. Math was not my thing. Um,
but when I'm 92 and he's 87,
um,
that may be the long game would have
worked here and he'll look back and go,
you know, Dave, you probably were right.
I suspect I will get him on this one.
So I would say just generally try to be,
try to be as tolerant as the
other people say they are.
They're not really that good at it.
They just talk about it a lot.
But if you actually try to do that and
realize that the world is not designed to
bow to you and that you can show
people you're a little bit better. I'm,
I just am a firm believer that that is
what will ultimately get there. But no,
you can't get everyone right there.
And it's for you to judge what
relationship do you want to be in.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I think to bring it home then a question,
and I think very important than probably
troubling or goes to the heart of
something that's troubling.
A lot of people now a Rochelle
on the men in the me to era.
I know it will bring it home
at that point, but Rochelle
was, Rachelle. Hey Roger.
Yeah,
I just wanted to be clear. I've never
had a me too and sit in with the woman.
Really good. I like that one. Yeah.
Yes, it is. First of all,
thank you very much for being
here and helping us to wake up.
I really appreciate it. So my question
is, as a redeemed progressive, uh,
what is the key to empowering men in
the me too age while maintaining healthy
boundaries and strong
behavioral expectations?
Well, as the redeemed
progressive is that he said, um,
well no one's born guilty.
No one's born guilty.
If you haven't raped anybody and you have
been accosted anybody and you haven't,
you know, done anything untoward, then
you have nothing to be guilty about it.
I mean, this is the consistent
theme that we've talked about here,
about why you should judge people as
an individual and not as a collective,
but they've created a situation now
where people are now being born with
original sin. Oh, you're a white
heterosexual, usually Christian male.
You are the worst thing that
exists and that not, I mean,
it's the essence of bigotry. It's your
prejudging, right? So that's prejudice.
You're looking at someone
and you're prejudging them
and you think that you know,
everything that there, uh, not
only about, but capable of. Um,
so I would say the further we can
get away from that, how do you,
how do you negotiate those relationships
while if you've done something bad?
It's on you. I mean, Jordan
addressed this already.
It's on you to figure out how to
make penance for that, I suppose.
But if you haven't done anything and most
people haven't, that's why this thing,
this idea, believe all women.
That's well that was like saying,
believe all men believe all midgets
believe all, I mean, it just doesn't, not,
not midgets. Now you're going to get
us in trouble. Yeah, for sure. Uh,
seeing you just walked into it. Yeah,
you did it to yourself this time. Um,
but it may,
I mean really we call little people.
Middle people believe all little
people. Um, but, but really,
I mean if you could just take the
reverse, they say, believe all women,
well now just do the other way or believe
all men. Does that sound right? You?
Of course you shouldn't believe all men
and you shouldn't believe all women.
And by the way, every time that this
happens with one of these people saying,
believe all women,
then the accusation gets turned on them.
Like our governor Gavin
Newsome in California,
or when it happened with Cory
booker or a series of these guys,
and then suddenly they go,
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, wait for
evidence when it was Kevin. Ah,
no, believe all women. So it's
a, it's a just a ridiculous,
untenable way of holding a position.
And if you're not guilty of something,
I mean that the fact that this is
happening to young people in the West,
especially in it,
especially young white men,
that they're walking around feeling
like they've done something when they've
done nothing. Uh, what a,
what a recipe for a disaster and the
type of totalitarian society that we've
been talking about up here.
Yeah. It's also reflective of a, of
a technical problem. I would say.
Um,
we've had relatively reliable
birth control since 1960.
Okay.
That's not very long.
And we underestimate the unbelievable
technological triumph of birth control.
It's, it's the hydrogen
bomb. It's the transistor.
Like it's a major league
transformation in human interaction.
Women are now free from
involuntary Ruppert reproduction.
That's never been the case in the
entire history of the planet. Okay.
We don't know exactly what
to do about that. Okay.
So the first idea in the 60s was,
hell,
let's party.
And you know,
you could see why it's like what the
rules for not engaging in promiscuous
sexual intercourse
seemed to have vanished.
So we had a couple of decades
of experimentation. It's like,
well,
how'd that go?
Little hard on the family.
I would say that's not so good for kids.
AIDS that wasn't a plus,
could've killed us all.
And it mutated particularly to
take advantage, promiscuous sex,
because viruses are very tricky things.
So it turns out that sex is a little
bit more complicated than we thought.
Well, it actually turns out that it's a
lot more complicated than we think. Okay.
And now it's four 50 60 years later
and we're trying to sort this out.
It's like, well, when is it
okay to have sex? Exactly.
And when is it not okay to have sex?
And what does it mean that it's okay and
what is consent me and answer to that
is,
well,
we never used to have to think these
things through because the rule was don't
have sex until you get married. That was
the rule. Now that isn't the rule. Okay,
so what's the rule? Well, we're not
having a conversation about the rule.
We're waiting until someone does something
that seems like it might be untoward
and then mobbing them and
trying to extract the rule
out that way and it's not a
very effective way of doing it. You
know, you want to decrease campus rape,
that's easy.
Get rid of alcohol.
No one has that conversation.
It's like I did my phd work on alcohol.
50% of the people who are murdered are
drunk and 50% of the people who kill them
are drunk and almost all of the date rape
situations are consequences of access
intoxication,
but yet there's a party culture
on campuses and anything goes.
And you also have this strange thing,
especially on the radical left, which is,
which is unbelievably paradoxical,
were absolutely every form of sexual
expression imaginable is 100% permissible
because sex is fine,
but it's so dangerous that while you're
dancing with someone at a Princeton
mixer,
you have to ask them two or three
times if it's okay for you to continue.
And, and that's, that's actually the
case by the way. I'm not making that up.
It's like, well, both of those things
can't be true. Now what's happening,
I think on the me too end of things and
the affirmative consent end of things is
the old sexual taboos are reasserting
themselves the idea that we can extract
sex out from emotional intimacy
and especially emotional intimacy.
I would say psychological intimacy maybe
even from longterm relationship is,
I don't believe it's a tenable idea.
I don't think we can do it.
And a lot of what we're seeing is the
backlash against that. It's like, well,
I feel used,
you know,
because one of the things that's happening
on the really radical end of the anti,
uh, sexual abuse movement
is the idea that, well,
if you have intercourse with someone
and then you regret it the next day,
that's evidence that it wasn't consensual.
Well,
it is in the sense evidence that it wasn't
consensual because it's evidence that
you didn't bloody well think it through,
right. It was good for last night,
but it's not good for today. It's
not very wise. The question is what?
What constitutes consent?
And we need to have a very
serious conversation about that.
Like under what circumstances is
it acceptable to give consent,
but we're not mature enough to have
that conversation. We want it both ways.
We want to be able to do whatever
we want with ever, with what,
with whoever we want,
whenever we want,
with no consequences and we want,
they're never to be any trouble
about consent. It's like, well, no,
that's not going to happen.
I don't think that sex works very well
outside of committed relationships.
I don't think there's any
evidence that it does.
There's a strong proclivity
across cultures for,
for the enforcement,
social enforcement of longterm monogamy.
And there's reasons for that.
And I think you deviate
from that at your peril.
So now if you,
if you want to deviate from that,
there's all sorts of reasons to do it on,
and I can understand why
people are interested in an
adventure and all of that.
But you know,
my sense also as a clinician is you don't,
you only really get to try out
about five people in your life.
You have to make a decision
pretty damn quick, you know,
like between 20 and 30 there's a lot of
things to get straight and longterm mate
is usually one of them.
And most of the time people should be
more careful with their sexual behavior
when they're young, specially
when they're drunk. Then they are.
And I think it,
I just think it's so interesting that
all of the taboo reconstruction is coming
from the radical left.
It's not what you'd expect at all.
You'd think it'd be the damn right wing
Christians complaining about, you know,
sexual immorality. It's like, no, it's
the radical lefties. You know. You,
you have to have signed consent before
making any physical move. And then that's,
so what really, who thought
that up? That's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard.
You know how awkward that would be?
You know you're supposed to be able to
do a little bit of nonverbal reading,
right? I mean that's part of
romance. You don't see in it.
You ever see a movie where the two people
who are dating exchange consent notes
like that doesn't happen.
So it's an unrealistic solution.
But I think the real solution is that
despite the fact that we have reliable
birth control,
we're going to have to relearn what the
acceptable rules of propriety are with
regards to sexual relationships.
One of the things I often tell my young
clients is don't do anything physically
with anyone that you would talk to
them about because if you're too damn
embarrassed to talk about it,
well maybe it's a little premature.
The relationship
to actually do it and then
there's harm in it. You know,
there's emotional harm in
it for on both parties.
There's the cheapening of both parties so
well, so it's going to take us
a long time to sort this out,
but hopefully we can do it in a serious
manner and it won't be merely a matter
of mobbing. Those who seem to
have made an error so well,
Jordan and dive, you've given us
unbelievably generously of your insights,
of your ideas, of your
experience, of your wisdom,
and you've done it with immense warmth
and humanity. I can't thank you enough,
and I think all of these good
Australians would in would agree with me.
[inaudible]
okay.